one of the nights he went drinking he
supposedly just kissed someone and how I
found out was he was FaceTiming me and
he stuck his tongue out and his tongue
was white and he's like what is this and
I was like that's a yeast infection
I don't think I've ever heard anything
like this in my life
Kalani reveals the shocking way she
found out I swell who cheated on her she
either kissed someone here you kiss
someone down there
and it's
um
yeah
and so irresponsible then he came home I
told him to please tell me the full
truth and then he disclosed that someone
had offered to give him a job
on top of that Kalani also shares how
after he cheated she cheated too getting
even with a quote Paul pass kiss
but it led to so much more
so did you
The Story Goes from bad to worse to bad
worse it really does let's talk about it
hey 90 day fans fam it's melissia oh the
last resort is finally here a show
that's going to help 90 day couples who
are struggling through different forms
of therapy and hopefully as we watch
we'll learn a thing or two ourselves
by the way I'll still be bringing you
the other way highlights but this week
it is all about the last resort my name
is asuelo I'm 27 years old and I'm from
Samoa I'm Kalani I'm 34 years old and
we're living in Southern California
right now we've been married almost five
years all right let's get into Kalani
revealing how she found out ashwelu
cheated on her starting from the top of
the episode the couples arrive at a
beautiful Resort in the Florida Keys
along with Kalani and asuelu we've got
Jovi and Yara Angela and Michael Molly
and Kelly Big Ed and Liz
in The Last Resort if you can sum it up
briefly what are we going to see what
can fans expect I think they can expect
a huge transformation of each and every
couple side note make sure you check out
my exclusive interview with them
it was interesting
I swear on Kalani made out of family
vacation bringing along their boys I
think the thing I'm most nervous about
with therapy is telling everyone our
business
between us right now it's really bad
our marriage is really hard and because
of me
we've had a lot of issues with
infidelity yeah we're about to see a lot
of Tears this episode
I'm obviously here to support my sisters
while they work on their marriage but my
biggest fear I guess is that he'll go
into therapy and not be honest and just
use his fake tears which I've seen
before
but if this doesn't work then they're
done so I think he is kind of panicking
I just don't think he's a trustworthy
person which is sad after the cast gets
reacquainted at the resort yeah fresher
there you go cheers to a fresh start
things get real as three therapists sip
the couples down for their first
counseling session
as well what brings you here I feel like
the reason why we're here is because of
me
I just need to
get
the answer of my own problems that I
have
I appreciate how there is this
understanding that this Retreat isn't
just about the work that they need to do
as a couple but more importantly the
work they need to do as individuals I am
a firm believer that relationships are
here to help us grow and evolve as human
beings
they can be our biggest teachers
so Australia went to Samoa to visit his
dad
all right let's take a look at Kalani
fully detailing how she first found out
ashwelu cheated while he was there he
was going out like all the time and
drinking
and one of the nights he went drinking
he supposedly just kissed someone and
how I found out was he was FaceTiming me
and he stuck his tongue out and his
tongue was white and he's like what is
this and I was like that's a yeast
infection you have thrush
and there's only certain ways you can
get it so you either kiss someone here
you kiss someone down there look at
Jovi's face and Yara couldn't help but
squirm in her chair
quite frankly this is embarrassing aside
from cheating being one of the most
ultimate forms of betrayal this just
shows how stepping out on your partner
can not only hurt your family
emotionally but it can potentially hurt
them physically too what if Kalani never
saw his tongue and he came home and
kissed her and then she went and kissed
their boys I know that's taking it kind
of far but I just don't understand how
you can risk your well-being and the
well-being of your family for a random
woman at a bar
that's just Reckless
it ain't worth it man then he came home
I told him to please tell me the full
truth and then he disclosed that someone
had offered to give him a job
and he accepted it so
I told him
that's a wrap I don't want to do this
anymore like I can't deal with that so
then to make it even or fair then he
said I could have a hall pass and then I
could go kiss someone if I wanted to
huh but he only told me that because he
thought I wouldn't do anything
I would never consider the option of a
hall pass in my marriage no matter what
the situation was if you're watching me
and you will get the yeast infection oh
you will not need to give it to me I
would just go I know that's right Yara
now I will say this it's always easy to
say what we wouldn't do when we're not
in that situation so I'm not judging
Kalani for staying with asuelu after
that
but I do have a very strong stance on
the hall pass situation
it's immature period This is a
full-blown marriage with two kids
involved why open the door to
potentially make things worse
as a therapist I do not believe the hall
pass is a good idea at all you're
inflicting more wounds more pain more
suffering it's a whole different element
now that you've added to this list of
problems they already have
I was a virgin when I met him and I was
almost 29 years old so I trusted him and
I loved him and I gave him literally
everything
laughs
so for him to just betray me and betray
me and betray me and betray me so for
him to finally say Okay betray me that
okay
I will the fact that Kalani is even
allowing oswello to rub her back right
now as she cries about the pain he
inflicted on her it's impressive she has
lots of patience for that man it would
have been easy to hit him with a
don't touch me
I told you
I know I told you that if you kept
acting the way that you're acting that
we weren't gonna be together and I bet
you I begged you to doctor so now we're
here
I know
I'm not saying we here because of you
I'm saying we here because of me
sharing this information not only in
front of other couples but in front of
the world
takes guts
I'm not sure how they're gonna come back
from this it is heart-wrenching to see
the level of distrust between the two of
them now for Kalani and asuelo the first
step is to be honest with each other it
still feels there's more to tell and
until we get to that place of awareness
of complete honesty we can't go forward
on that path because it just keeps
sabotaging well Dr PD was right there is
some more information being held back
Kalani goes on to share that she not
only kissed another guy but she went all
the way with him in fact I swallow
didn't know until this moment I got to
know this other guy we did kiss each
other
it escalated further to oral sex
[Music]
oh
and then after that it escalated into
actual sex look at us breathing out hard
wow man
I don't know where there's a cheer her
because she could do that or say Kalani
what the hell are you doing I want to
slap out as well over giving her the
whole passion only the truth that was
the dumbest movie could have made in
your marriage
so did you
wow
Kalani said
you give the Virgin girl a pass now
she's never gonna go wanna go back
it's like she just gonna feel the taste
of all of that and he create that now
really he created that that's his
mistake I will never judge Colonial that
she had another boyfriend or something
because he created
I love Yara you know one of my favorite
Parts about the series so far is seeing
the other couple's reactions and hearing
their commentary everybody has the most
Sound Advice when it's not their
relationship on display
Kalani goes on to say she met this
mystery guy on social media and she
didn't expect her to go anywhere but
they ended up having a solid connection
and that's something that's been missing
in my marriage for years now I know who
this man is they met on social media
no that's common but
I wasn't expecting that
is he a fan now there are some reports
that he will make an appearance on the
show that
I can't wait to see
it's so painful because today I saw her
still texting him still talking to him
even though they broke up
she still have
this relationship connection but for me
I didn't talk to the people
that I have you know doing all of this
[__] so now
we have a lot more revealed uh yeah
and when Kalani and oswello get back to
their room even more is revealed
after I swallow ask Kalani a question
that deep down he probably really didn't
want to know the answer to
did you enjoy sex with you did did he do
better like did you feel better
than what I did or
okay do you want me to be honest yep
okay
the difference between you and him is
that when me and you have sex it's about
you it's about what you want it's about
what like you getting what you need from
it with him it's about both of us seems
like Kalani is now dealing with a grown
man Yara was right how is she gonna go
back to I swear After experiencing that
that's a game changer I don't really
understand because when we have sex like
I try to do what you want but I usually
when you have sex with a girl you're
supposed to try to make her finish you
know I usually do that do you
so it actually is like he's better than
me I'm not gonna say that
let me say this differently how your
selfishness of how self-centered you are
in your everyday life about like let me
do this and let me do that and leave my
wife to do everything you do that also
sexually
so everything revolves around you damn
Kalani then calls I swallow wild for
asking these egocentric questions
instead of getting to what truly matters
even the questions you're asking you're
not saying like oh what did I do to make
you feel that way what did I do to make
you go to someone else I didn't want to
be with anybody else
I only wanted to be with you
do you really have feelings for him
of course
of course this mystery man has opened
her up to A Whole New World
all jokes aside when you abuse it you
lose it and we've watched I swear we'll
take his relationship with Kalani for
granted now I'm not saying she's been
perfect but asuelo has definitely had
some maturing to do and sometimes those
hard lessons
come at a cost all right 90 day fans fam
The Last Resort is just getting started
and if this is the introduction
what do we have in store
make sure you stick with ET because we
are covering it off I will see you next
time
foreign